yeah i don't like that that postmates i
don't i don't i don't know who he was i
don't know you personally but this is
just a try like i do this all the time i
talk to women four days a week and this
is a trend i see is they submit to the
rapper guy and then he treats them bad
and then they say oh no but i can't
trust men uh the next guy i need to put
up all these walls i need to make him
wait to have sex i need to make him do
this do this do this and this is the
good man that would actually marry you
so the problem is really the problem is
who you choose as women that is the
problem is you are choosing wrong as
women you are attracted to the wrong
things and you are choosing the wrong
types of men and then what happens is
when it goes south based on your
decisions by the way not the man's
decisions or not other men's decisions
who aren't your man when it goes south
what you are trying to do is make the
next man
pay for something that he didn't
actually do and so what it is
is that you need to learn to choose
better men from the get-go i do agree
with that kind of but not really because
you know what the craziest thing is
nowadays
this is why i say being submissive is
also another problem because when you
submissive in the name of love and i'll
tell you something he wasn't just a
rapper when i met him it wasn't because
he was a rapper actually i mean even i
met him in person through family friends
it was amazing he was an amazing person
and then he had the dream of wanting to
be a rapper and that's how i supported
him his dream right and i've generally i
thought oh wow this person's amazing he
just switched on me and this is the
thing i am not and you did nothing
out of the blues
when it comes to when it comes to um
it's not i didn't do anything but
there's there's your character is shown
in certain situations you've got a
choice to make you can abuse somebody or
you can leave how many how many years in
did you see the red flag maybe like
first second year so and then you stayed
for three or four yes and is that on you
a little bit because it's accountability
but this is being a psychologist you
kind of you understand a little bit more
about being a victim of abuse it's not
always that you're consciously making
the decision to stay because you're dumb
and you know no better you get to a
point where you're insecure and you're
depressed and gets to that stage and
this is what i say about being
submissive to a man you need to ensure
that there's trust respect and there's
love because those three things will
make submission make sense otherwise if
you're just teaching people to women to
be submissive all the time but you
submit it to the wrong man exactly and
let me tell you what it what the problem
is because i believed that for you to be
in a successful relationship you have to
be submissive so as a woman i was
submissive to the wrong person i fell
into a trap and this is what i'm trying
to say things need to make sense it's
not just about submit as a woman you
need to create and build a relationship
based on mutual respect that's the only
way submission makes sense i don't think
you're understanding though because
you're submissive you're submitting to
like bad boys because that's what
majority of females are attracted to so
if you're submissive to bad boys and the
good guy comes you're not going to be
submitted you're going to give him
masculine energy before he was a bad boy
he was a good boy hang on how about that
so he's okay but you but you submitted
one to two years in so the majority of
the relationship you knew he was a bad
boy and you submitted so so that's what
i'm saying he's correct what he's saying
is based on he's he is because it's
based off the words that came out of
your mouth so okay
i'll go back and explain okay so i
submitted for one year by then i'm in
love and i'm already thinking we're
going to get married you're the love of
my life okay year two things start to go
a bit south year three i'm thinking wow
this is not really great yeah was he a
rapper was he a rapper all of these like
probably from years year one towards
okay so so i'll i'll give you i'll give
you something i'm sorry to stop you so
when so when he's rapping what type of
lyrics are coming out of his mind
actually and this is the thing he's
talented he didn't talk no no
everybody's quite woke no i believe that
listen to us listen to what i'm asking
you right when he's rapping is he
talking about [ __ ] money blah blah
blah all this kind of stuff no no and
this is this is what i'm saying i
supported him also because it made sense
so he was that it was like a will smith
type right he's good he's quite woke he
said he was extremely talented and he
said things in a way that i appreciate
there was value in these lyrics and this
is what i'm saying they're submission
you submit submit you fall in love and
then he gets to a point where he's like
nowadays people think commitment is
rubbish people don't commit i thought
actually i need to commit i've made my
choice i've found somebody that i do
love although things are not right i've
already submitted i'm here and i need to
commit otherwise probably i'll end up
lonely and have the fear of the being 13
being childless and i was in a bad
situation with a dog or a cat which one
do you prefer fish they're prettier and
easier you prefer a fish yeah i'll be
outside there's some kind of pet some
kind of pet or maybe not have a pet like
you know i want a bearded dragon i'll
probably have a baby you want a baby
what's a bearded dragon bit of dragon
like an iguana yeah but a smaller one
it's really cute i mean people are
scared but so do you sorry to switch it
day do you think women nowadays
understand what it is to be in a
long-term relationship and hold down a
relationship
do you think women understand what that
is there's a lot of commitment sorry
linda's like linda's shaking head sorry
go on linda no i i don't think they do
um because i don't think it's it's it's
just still instilled in them
i just feel as though they put a lot of
emphasis on the physical and i think
if you're dating to get married there
are certain things that you need to
agree upon and i don't think
in my experience with a lot of girls
that i talk to that call me about boy
advice and such
i ask what are your values what it what
do you believe in what are your
political what are your
religious if you're religious do you
want does he want kids where do you
where do you want to live in the city do
you want to live in the sub the suburbs
the countryside they don't know these
things
about themselves so how can you or and
even guys too like how can you how can
you date if you don't
have common ground on those things
can i ask you a question how many women
are here there's like there's four of us
and we keep talking about women as if
like ask me if i know what i want i'll
tell you exactly where i want to live oh
we can definitely tell that you you
would definitely tell us you know what
you're doing i'm just saying i can tell
you because obviously i like to speak
like this it's fun i like being fiery
fine but i'm sure angel knows i'm sure
imagine us i'm sure you know not every
single okay
okay so what is it what does it take to
be in a long what do you think it takes
to be in a long-term relationship and
hold it down i think number one 100 your
intentions
i think when you meet somebody for the
first time number one normalize dating
for marriage because
there's two completely separate worlds
out there there's dating for marriage
and there's dating uh the modern woman
yeah the modern man internet dating
meeting just to have sex so let's put
that to the side if you're trying to
date somebody to be with them forever
then it's about your intentions so
number one
intentions number two make sure you're
compatible
if you're not i always say if i'm dating
somebody then if i'm not going to be
with them for the rest of my life then
why am i going to be dating them if it's
not working and we've discussed things
then i don't need to just be dating you
for no reason so
that's it really for me i think if
you're the right person in a partnership
and it's gonna work then it's gonna work
and then you can hold it down together
and it moves into a separate
conversation about what what more do you
need
but i think that very first basis your
best friend you need to be best friends
have the good intentions together and be
compatible and then from then on
everything else you build on with your
partner what do you think andrew no i
think she said it all to be fair for me
i feel like i totally agree and you need
to
i feel like you just have to
like yeah just what you said best
friends because like without
if you're just in a relationship with
this person and you're not like
you know like close in some sort of ways
like as close friends or anything like
that it's i don't think it's gonna ever
work if it's just sex and all these
things and then yeah i just think that
you should be close i think it's a
massive generation thing that's
different as well like if you look at
you know our parents grandparents it's
completely different completely
different so earlier on when i was
asking you
as many of you know i was just banned on
tic tac and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible